[Captions by Y Translator]
Guys, today, we're going
to be taking a look
at how to make some sort
of post apocalyptic weapons.
[Music]
There's YouTube channel
called Make or Break
that has a video showing
how they made some throwing
knives modeled after those seen
in the game Far Cry 4.
We thought those looked really cool,
and we wanted
to try doing something similar,
but with a little bit
of a twist on it.
So today, I'm here
with my friend Clay,
and we are going to try
and make some Far Cry 4 knives,
but in sort
of a post-apocalyptic way.
We've come to an area
where there just
happens to be a lot
of vehicles that are
not in prime condition...
And we're going to try
and harvest materials from here
that we can then use
to make these knives.
Here is the basic idea.
We've got two hacksaw
and some pliers,
and we're going to find
what looks like good throwing
knife material on a car,
chop that off, and then
shape it into what we want.
So Clay, why are we here
with all these broken down cars?
Well, so in a post-apocalyptic
world, of course,
they're going to be tons
of broken down cars.
And that.
So logically, that's
the first place you'd go,
and a new I would be a little
bit expensive for the budget.
So we're going to take advantage
of what we have available to us,
and use this as a source
of good cheap materials.
I think what we're looking
for is some pretty straight
flat-ish pieces of steel,
ideally, something
that's like around an eighth
of an inch thick.
Enough thickness that we
can carve into a little bit,
give it some shape,
and really make it look
like what we're going for.
I think...
I think I'll take it.
What are you--
What are you asking for it?
$20.
Sold.
[Music]
Okay, we found
this pretty sweet truck.
It had what looks
like some sort of carrying
system built into it,
and I think we can try
harvesting some pieces of that.
It has some angle iron
that I think's going to be
the perfect thickness for it.
Yeah, I think we might try
and snag this whole
piece off right here.
So how long its going to take
us to cut through this?
Forever?
[Music]
Yes!
So this angle iron is
like perfect thickness.
It's about 1/8 inch thick,
which should be the perfect size
for making some throwing knives.
Very cool.
So now, we are going to take
this back to our studio.
I know it said post-apocalyptic,
but I was referring
to our source for materials.
We're going to cheat
a little bit,
and use some not quite
apocalyptic tools to finish
this bad boy up.
Okay, we've got
our bar right here
that we cut off of our...
Truck.
Weirdly demolished truck,
and we've got a picture of the
knife that were trying to make.
So now, I think we're going
to do is print this out,
and we're going to glue
that onto our bar,
and that's going to be
our guide for the shape
we're trying to make.
[Music]
I printed out a picture
of the knife.
That's the size we want,
and I just sanded down this
piece of metal a little bit,
because it's all
covered in rust,
and I want to be able
to glue this down
onto the metal right there,
so we can basically just
cut right around it.
[Music]
All right, and now the fun part,
which is just so
very much cutting...
Yeah.
Until we have this all removed.
So right now, we're just
going to take a drill bit,
and drill out
these contour edges here.
So then we don't have to later
on take a file to them
to really get them.
And if we cut the rest
of the profile
of the knife out first,
then like we have a really hard time
getting the drill bit to stay in place.
[Music]
All right.
Now, the really fun part,
we get to start cutting
all of that out.
We could use a jigsaw.
We could use the hacksaw.
We can use an angle grinder,
but we can start with hacksaw
while I run and get
some metal blades if you want.
Oh, so I see how it is.
You go get the metal blades
for the jigsaw,
and I start with a hacksaw.
That's very fair.
[Music]
Done.
Woo.
[Music]
We've got our basic
shape cut out.
What's our next step?
So, we need to take
either a file,
or if you have
an angle grinder,
that works too.
We just need to kind
of finish shaping,
because if you noticed,
it's definitely not the correct
shape we really want,
and then we also want to put
bevels on the knife edge of it.
Start with the file,
and see how well we're getting
things done with that.
But we actually want the handle
right here tapered
outward that way.
Right.
So when we wrap
the paracord around it,
it won't just slip off.
Right, not parallel.
Just not--
They're currently curved
is what I'm...
>> Yeah.
[Music]
We've got the profile
all cut and filed out.
Clay, what's our next step?
So we want to cut
and drill a few holes out here
at the base of the handle,
so you can have a nice...
Rounded removed area
from the handle.
So I think you could put a strap
or a cord through it.
Yeah.
And then after that,
we're going to start adding
the taper on to the blades,
right at the bevel.
Yes, we're going
to do the bevels,
and we're not going to make
them like perfectly sharp.
For a throwing knife,
you kind of want
them dull a little bit.
[Music]
So now, we've added
our little slot in the back.
And we want to start
adding a bevel,
and I've marked off,
before I tore the paper off,
I marked off where we want
the bevel to go on each side.
[Music]
That's basically what
we're going for is
removing all of this.
[Music]
We're going to cheat,
because filing takes
a really long time.
So to take
slightly shorter forever,
we are going to use power tools.
Because in this
post-apocalyptic world...
Everybody have this.
>> Everybody has power tools.
[Music]
We got our shape
pretty well cut out,
and filed and
sanded and everything.
Now, we need to make
it look a little bit more
like the one in the game.
So we're going to take
a little bit of spray paint,
and just age it up a bit.
[Music]
So now that we've got
the finished knife,
now, we're going to make
the handle wrap for it.
So what we're going
to do is just going
to take some paracord.
We're going to loop it
around the top like that,
and then make sure you've got
some extra line down here
so you can pull on that later.
And then just start
wrapping wherever you want
the handle the start.
You can do this pretty tightly.
Just keep going up
until you want
the handle to stop.
But make sure this loop
stays above the,
where you want
the handle to stop.
[Music]
So when you get to this point
where you want it to stop,
just tuck that extra piece
of paracord right in,
and then you just pull
on this back piece,
and that will cinch it down.
It's not going to go anywhere.
And then just cut
off this excess.
And if you want,
you can take a lighter
and carefully melt this,
and that will really keep it
from coming apart.
We've got our finished handle.
Booyah, we've got
a finished throwing knife made
out of a piece of an old car.
And now of course,
we need to test this out.
So let's--
Now, of course,
we need to test this out.
So let's grab
a scrap piece of wood,
and see if we can throw this
and get it to stick.
[Music]
So I had Clay here showing us
how to do this,
because he has actually
done this before.
You can see he has
his own knife,
and I have the one
that we've made just today.
And so now,
we can just both tell
them with the target.
Oh.
Yeah.
It poked through the plywood.
Yes, what?
3, 2, 1.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
We're Champion knife throwers.
We don't show all the takes,
we just show the last one.
That's how it's done.
Guys, that's it for today,
but that's not all
there is to see.
That box at the top will take
you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you haven't subscribed
to our channel yet,
just hit this bomb
to get in the club.
That way, you'll never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.